hi I'm Bruce Lee its sky pop we have a
vision of a new class of mobile
experience something that's never been
possible before at least not before the
Android platform
I'm here with Timo Brock our CTO and
he's going to share with you what it's
like being down and dirty day one on the
Android platform so day one like most
engineers I got that Android platform
serve writing hello world and I end up
with a Sudoku game I just bypass hello
world all together came out with a nice
graphical application
I've never anything like that so fast on
it on a mobile device the the platform
is just that easy to use day two is like
okay well what am I gonna do with this
platform so I kind took the location API
sand the the view and map api's put them
together and wrote a friend finder
application I mean see where all your
friends are you get Maps just like
Google Maps on the web but it's on your
cell phone even have a little cup us
down here in the corners to help you
find them if you want try to navigate
the maze it's kind of like you know Star
Trek it's your tricorder but to find
find friends instead of finding a aliens
so then I'm gonna take the next step
that's like well let's do some let's do
a kind of friend finders plus games what
can you do there so then I get the idea
of just doing a kind of a team
geocaching you know the already know
where your friends are know where your
opponents are can draw a map it has the
location of the cache has your friends
you can send all taunting messages you
know when you think your foes are not
really catching up to you and again I
focus spent all my time just working on
the application on the creative part
that I wants to do everything else just
provided by the platform so there's a
lot of fun productive and you know kind
of joy to work with which was a pleasure
for mobile device we at Sky pop can't
wait for the first Android devices to
hit the market so that you can see what
we're really up to and so that we can
see all the great things that you're
going to develop see you soon